Five signs and an ambivert likes you
With approximately two-thirds of a population being ambiverts, chances are you've crossed paths with your fair share throughout your life
Maybe you even fit this category an ambivert represents traits of both introversion and extraversion
meaning that while they enjoy social interactions imparting they also appreciate their time alone every once in a while and
Hey, maybe you don't fit this group, but you found yourself attracted to an ambivert and want to know if they return the feelings
Here are five signs and ambivert likes you
1) They single you out at large gatherings
While ambiverts can find enjoyment from being around other people. They usually felt more at ease among small groups or having one-on-one
Conversation if they've ever singled you out at a party
Chances are they are interested in interacting with you in a setting where they were most comfortable
2) Spontaneously asking you to hang out
Ambiverts attitudes can change depending on whether they're on a work or school setting as opposed to a more social one
Because of this you might at first think them to be very introverted
Only to be surprised later when they ask you to come along maybe even with a few of their friends
This is because while ambierts need their time alone
they might also find comfort in small groups in order to rest from there's more solitary work environment and
because of the sudden bursts of extroversion they might just work up the courage to ask you out
3) They seem to be hesitating around you even
If an ambivert ever seems to be fluctuating in the attitude with which approach you this might be why
Think of the introverted and extroverted sides of an ambivert arguing over
What's best for their social life while one side might shy away from the social interaction their
extroverted side really wants to stay and talk to you
It's not at all that they've changed their minds about you all of a sudden. In fact
it's such an important decision for them. They can't let themselves take you lightly
This translates into their online interactions as well
4) Inconsistent interactions online
An ambivert might stay up to talk to you until 5:00 a.m.. One day and then proceed to completely disappear from social media the next
Remember an ambivert needs their alone time as much as their social time. This behavior doesn't mean they've lost interest all of a sudden
Simply that they must recharge on their own with some alone time
If you can wait this out, they'll appreciate your patience as well as continue interacting with you once they're fully ready to be social again.
5) They show you their playful side and their serious side
As your relationship with an ambivert deepens you start to discover more and more layers to their
personality. This means they're letting you into their own little world which can be a sight
completely different from the one you saw when you first met them perhaps
they were in very talkative before but as you got to know them they began to show their playful side.
A side of them that in the end is all part of the same person
and they're letting you in on all of this because they're comfortable around you
These are some signs an ambivert might like you have you met someone who has shown one or more signs around you
Maybe this list has helped clear some things up
Hey everybody, I just want to give a personal
thank you video for you guys for always supporting Psych2Go and making this all possible for us. Our vision is to make
Psychology as accessible as possible so that it promotes self-awareness and it helps you guys grow.
However we want to make more content for you guys and would love your support in buying one of these bracelets from our partner Introvert Palace
Check out the bracelet
It's pretty cool, and it even includes Pluto the link to purchase will all be in the description below
And I hope you guys have an amazing day. Bye!